malas noticias para el medio ambiente a
partir de ahora la lucha contra la
crisis climática en eeuu será un poco
más difícil después de que la corte
suprema- limitar el poder de acción de
la agencia medioambiental epa algo que
ha generado rechazo entre los expertos y
ecologistas
lo que el cambio climático es una crisis
existencial
y este tribunal muy ideológico está más
preocupado por limitar al gobierno que
por abordar esta crisis
es como si estuvieras en una guerra y
decidieras bueno el gobierno no puede
asumir los poderes que necesita para
luchar y es que ahora el gobierno
federal no podrá imponer límites en las
emisiones de dióxido de carbono de las
empresas un fallo que socava la agenda
climática del gobierno de joe biden que
está estudiando la forma de reducir las
emisiones y que también ha generado
críticas entre la comunidad
internacional y sus decisiones como la
de eeuu o cualquier otra importante
economía emisora hacen más difícil
cumplir con los objetivos del acuerdo de
parís pensar para un planeta sano y
habitable especialmente cuando
necesitamos acelerar la eliminación del
carbón y la transición a energías
renovables
esta decisión llega después de la
supresión del derecho al aborto por
parte de la corte sin embargo el órgano
judicial se ha dado su visto bueno para
eliminar la polémica ley quédate en
mexico aplicada por la administración
trump y que retenía a los solicitantes
de asilo en méxico bajo el pretexto de
la pandemia no obstante son muchos los
que ponen en duda la imparcialidad del
organismo compuesto por seis
conservadores frente a tres liberales